[Music]
foreign
welcome to another episode of the after
show I am your host Nikki Novak and
today we are going to be deep diving
into could you guess it Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny we're gonna be
talking about everything to do with the
film the critic score the audience score
the box office where they go from here
and I should warn you that this is a
spoiler-filled episode so if you haven't
watched Indiana Jones in the dial of
Destiny and you don't want it spoiled
then stop right here go watch the film
and then come back I'm cracking that
whip I'm making sure that you don't we
don't spoil it for you
um but today I'm very very excited to be
joined by Joe Aragon he is the host of
the House of Cinema podcast welcome
thank you for having me I'm really
excited to talk about Indiana Jones I
like the whip joke I was very smart I
hope everybody caught that
we're filming this on a Monday
for the fourth
age so I feel like I'm a little like I
appreciate that I even got anything in
there but um just your only your first
time joining this actual show so welcome
thank you yeah I'm excited I was on the
Rotten Tomatoes wrong show so you may
have recognized my voice there or my
face uh but I'm excited to talk about
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny a
lot of thoughts can we talk about your
face for a second sure we start what's
my face reminds me of Karen caulkham
from succession which I told you before
we started rolling that's true but you
do get this once in a while yeah yeah we
had this conversation first thing Nikki
goes who do people say you look like and
I was like I don't know I don't know
but yeah Kieran Culkin I do get Kieran
Culkin sometimes once in a while you
know like I said Adrian Brody because we
have the you know we have the same nose
but Kieran I'll I'll take it I'll take
it I love him so much the highest praise
the highest praise I'll take it should
we talk about succession for the next
hour instead baby people might like that
a little bit more we'll see we'll see
let's start let's dive into the film um
so first of all let's talk about the
Tomato Meter score this premiere date
can quite a while ago it feels like now
it's been it's such a long summer with
so many Blockbusters that does it feels
like six months ago to me now but the
Tomato underscore is fresh at 68 the
audience score a delightful 88 and the
box office
opening weekend not so amazing 60
million dollars opening weekend we will
talk about this a little bit later but
let's uh give you a little bit of an
idea of the critics consensus it's not
as thrilling as earlier Adventures but
the nostalgic Rush of seeing Harrison
Ford back in Action helps Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny find a final few
bits of cinematic treasure so I'm going
to throw this over to you Joe and what
are your initial thoughts on critic
score audience score who are your most
in alignment with we haven't talked to
anything we haven't we haven't I have no
idea how you feel about it I know I was
so eager to say things before the
podcast but I wanted to save it for the
episode
I feel like this is a pretty
representative of how I feel at least on
the critics side of things no 68 was
it's a lot higher than what initially
this came out at commission it came out
of can was uh frightfully low people
were a little nervous about it we'll
probably get into that a little later
too but the overall consensus on the
critic side I think is representative
how I feel the audience is a little bit
more positive a little bit they like a
little bit more which I think makes
sense considering we're dealing with
this very nostalgic character in Indiana
Jones but I I feel overall the the same
as this score how do you feel
um
I am a huge Indian Jones fan
I and I really am like
jonesing to know like you're the
original trilogy your order because I
have I think there's only one correct
answer oh wow all right well hopefully I
get it right but I I feel like I've been
sitting with this movie for a while I
was lucky enough to interview
um Harrison and Phoebe back in January
wow
um for our big ticket show and so I feel
like I dove into this so long ago that
when I finally saw it I had so much
expectation yeah and then you know when
you were interviewing people you go back
and you I watch it all in succession and
and I really enjoyed the movie overall
and I feel like
I don't know what happened with the
initial response I can because it was
lower than the current score and it
actually came up once people in America
and people other people started to see
it closer to the opening
um
I think it's a good film yeah like
mangled is a great director all of the
elements work I love Harrison Ford I
loved Phoebe Waller bridge I thought she
was absolutely delightful I thought
there were so many things that did work
um and I think the problem is right now
in terms of taking an action-adventure
movie and it's in the summertime when
you have Mission Impossible opening in
two weeks and you have like so many
other big action movies I feel like
unconsciously or consciously people
compare right and so you have like when
I think about it like a movie like
Mission Impossible coming out where Tom
Cruise is performing all his own stunts
and he's 60 versus Harrison Ford who's
80 and yeah performing some stunts but
it's not the same I think it's harder to
Maybe please the audience and something
that I found
that I think maybe people are having a
hard time with it's very hard to you're
also thinking of like our modern day and
age of movie sensibilities and we're so
used to superhero movies and Marvel
movies being these big Blockbusters and
you have a film like this that feels
more like classic filmmaking and almost
like a throwback and it said in the 60s
it's not set in current day and so I
think it's it's a tougher cell does that
make sense it makes sense yeah I think
that strangely enough I think the
problem
maybe most people are having or maybe
critics are having right now is that it
does feel like it's you know a flashback
to the 60s and the 80s type of uh action
adventure movie but it also seems like
it's trying to balance being a modern
Blockbuster trying to fit in with the
Marvel movies the DC movies these big
superhero movies when it's never had to
really be that kind of movie but it's
trying to do those two things at once
trying to be a Marvel movie but also
trying to be a Raider's a lost ark or
Last Crusade okay so tell me how you
think it is trying to be a Marvel movie
because I actually don't think it is oh
so I would say it's trying to be a
Marvel movie because of its big action
set pieces that are in my opinion maybe
a little bit too long so we're dealing
with like this big uh Rickshaw car chase
which is uh almost and this might be a
kind of a stretch but I almost feels
fast and furious-esque where it lasts a
really long time and it's a little a
little ridiculous you could say when you
have you know 80 year old Harrison Ford
jumping from Rickshaw or Rickshaw and
all these big moments where it's like oh
someone's hanging from the hood of a car
not that Indiana Jones has always been
void of you know adventure action
sequences but never to this magnitude
and it does feel like sometimes this
movie is trying to say oh look at us
we're all so cool like these big movies
like Fast and Furious like the Marvel
movies look at this big chase scene uh
look at Harrison Ford ride a horse in
the middle of the street with all these
you know parades going on and uh cars
going by so at times it feels like it's
trying to be this big Blockbuster but
also like hey also let's get some puzzle
solving moments like you know Raiders or
last Crusades so I think it's trying to
balance these two sides of this one coin
and that's where it's getting stuck in
this middle for some people interesting
because it actually now that you say
that I can see what you're saying
because when I think of like Rick Sean I
think of the big action set pieces like
the train sequence I'm like this is
classic Indie like but you're right they
are stretched out and that's generally
not even with this movie but my issue
with I feel like so many movies now is
they're all 20 minutes too long if this
was a long movie it's like and a half
hours or more yeah and I felt like
Guardians 3 as much as I loved that was
too long but I'm overall I'm more in
line with the audience and I'm I'm very
um precious over my Nostalgia films and
because I do feel like
we judge films now I feel like we're so
as audiences as critics we're so hard on
every movie do you remember like I you
know like when these movies came out
like when the original trilogy came out
in the 80s early 90s
you basically went to the theater
and sometimes you didn't even know what
you were gonna go see you would go to
the theater and you'd be like should we
see this or this or this and you were
thrilled with what you saw and now we're
so spoiled for Choice with streaming and
films and I feel like everybody's a
Critic online and yeah and so I feel
like we're so much harder on these films
than we than we would have been in the
80s that's why it's harder to compare
these two because
I I thought it was I thought it was a
great movie overall I felt like it was
too long and that's where I lost me but
overall I thought they did a I thought
they did a great job
um so do you feel like this was like
when you when you think about because we
are going to spoiler territory like the
ending of where this ended up is like is
this a Justified ending for his
character because this is I guess it for
at least for Harrison Ford yeah so we're
not talking about the the uh the plot
twist ending but maybe like the last
like we're talking about the last 10
minutes maybe because overall his Arc in
this film I mean he's a little bit more
downtrodden than he has been in past
films I mean understandably so
um but also some people are arguing that
he didn't need to be like at the
beginning where he was at the end of his
career and he was sort of like his
students didn't appreciate him some
people felt like they didn't they didn't
need to start in that place he should he
could have been a little bit more of a
hero in this in that day and age I think
the ending works really well if I'm
being completely honest it's actually
one of my favorite Parts about this
movie is that I think what I love about
this movie is that it's less of a story
about this big adventure I mean
obviously Adventure but also it's a
story about a man grappling with his
past and really being stuck in the past
wanting to live in the past because his
current present life isn't what he
wanted to be you know he's divorced his
son has passed away which is an
interesting way to kind of canonically
move on from Mutt Williams but uh I
think it's you know it's about a guy
trying to reckon with his past and I
love that the ending you know he wants
to stay in the past he literally tells
uh you know Helena leave me here in this
ancient time of Sicily and she's like no
you know you need to come back and she
she punches him and he comes back that's
a great Moment by the way great moment
yeah and I think what makes that
especially great is that it feels like
it's a parallel to uh modern audiences
it's almost like man's gold is telling
audiences like you're kind of stuck in
the past as well too many people are
stuck in the past watching Indiana Jones
and we want to live in Nostalgia we want
to live with Raiders and Last Crusade
and Temple of Doom uh but we need to
kind of wake up ourselves and and move
to the present and I think that it's
like a nice little parallel between the
movie and modern audiences and I like
that she punches him and he's like has
to like realize I can't live in the past
anymore so I love the ending to this
movie I think it is a really nice
send-off for Indiana Jones overall
because he does learn to move on and
live his life as it currently is so I I
like the ending how do you feel
um I loved that moment like that moment
really worked and I truly thought in
that moment he was going to stay in the
past and I thought that's because we're
going to get into in a second a lot of
the rumors that we're circulating about
what was happening in this film
which apparently now I'm learning there
were never test audiences to even leak
anything so I don't know how these
things got started but
I had heard about time travel and I was
like oh this is how it's gonna end is
Indiana Jones is going to be left and
that's how we conclude a story I had no
idea she was gonna pop him in the face
oh yeah and that was such a like it was
a laugh out loud moment in my screening
I know you went to the premiere I was
out of screening and it was just one of
those great like oh my gosh I didn't
expect that like thank you for doing
that because we don't need him but I was
like thinking like the one thing that I
think would have been fun would be like
I love the humor and the optimism of and
the quirky jokes and the one-liners of
earlier Indiana Jones and I was like
wouldn't it have been funny if he
actually was she was like okay you do
you stay you do your thing and then he
goes running and then he like has
somebody running after him with his
spear or something
like he he made the choice yeah like he
decided rather than the other way around
um
but I didn't have a pro I didn't have a
problem with the way that moment played
out I think it's just things that we do
as we create oh that would have been
cool yeah or like when we call short
rounds in the movie yeah I think a lot
of people were like well wondering if
you know people from his pet I mean
clearly some people from his past do
show up but I think a lot of people may
have expected The Nostalgia factor to be
heightened and I'm actually glad it
wasn't I think it's easy to kind of rely
on past characters or moments to you
know get a positive reaction from the
audience fan service fan service is a
big thing and I'm glad they didn't lean
too much into that the little bit we got
I think was perfect you know we get the
moment with you know what what part
hurts me yes and they point I thought
that was a perfect like kind of callback
to Raiders um that isn't too on the nose
but still a really nice way to kind of
mend their relationship uh but I I think
I love the ending I think it's a really
nice way to say it's time to move on for
India as well and I think you know like
you mentioned it would have been
Harrison or Indiana Jones making that
decision himself I think the movie is
about the fact that he's been doing
things by himself the whole time and he
needs to realize it's okay to get help
from people whether that be Helena would
that be Marion whether it be whoever
he's with so I like that she made the
decision to like pop him in the face and
tell him no you need to come back home
yeah I don't know I'm critic because
it's one of the it's actually one of my
favorite moments in the film I think
it's just like sometimes we go oh that
would have been cool yeah and it would
have been better or worse it's just some
it's just an idea I had
um so there was a lot of
um
there was a lot of rumors like I
mentioned about what was going to happen
in this film and some people thought
that Phoebe wellerbridge was going to
become Harrison Ford's replacement and
where the Hat literally people know it's
actually me and I took the Hat oh yeah
yeah good to be here don't tell them but
um how did you feel about her character
and the way that that relationship
played out in the film I love her
character I mean Phoebe wallerbridge
doesn't really can't do any wrong in my
book uh if she can do anything and I
probably will like it but I really liked
her character and I think Helena is an
interesting
I wouldn't call her a foil to Indiana
Jones I think she's just kind of a
mirror to what he was when he was
younger she's very much like him but I
love her and I love her Dynamic with
India I love that she's also somebody
who's trying to deal with her own past
you know with her father I really liked
her her role in this movie I was a big
fan of it now the future of Indiana
Jones whether that include her or not
um I don't know I think that would have
been an interesting choice I don't think
I'd have been opposed to it at all how
do you feel
um I think it's
I think maybe I don't think that was
ever the case like I don't think it was
ever written that way James Mangold was
like I don't know where you're all
getting this from because I was never
the way it was intended to be I'm
curious where they'll go with it but I
do know that when I watched
the film next like I always take notes
and next to her name I wrote Star
because I thought it was a star
performance yeah I thought she was
incredibly charismatic and I just felt
like
there's there was like a relaxed quality
to the way she delivered her lines that
I don't know if I could have been that
relaxed acting opposite him and maybe I
was projecting and she is an actress and
this is what she does but sometimes I
feel like
when somebody comes into a franchise and
it's one movie you have one movie to
sort of have a whole character Arc and
you know become loved by audiences
versus characters that we are nostalgic
with it's it's a harder it's an uphill
battle and I thought she was Perfection
opposite him she held her own the one
issue that I had was
she started out and I loved the bit in
the beginning when they were in the
university and she takes off on him and
locks him in and she's just like sorry
I was like oh my gosh I wasn't expecting
now where she's just full on a thief but
then it switches over to where they are
allies and I wasn't really sure when it
switched over and and at what point
do you know what I mean like the
relationship definitely evolved yeah but
I feel like there was like one scene
that was maybe deleted or something that
sort of informed me it does jump pretty
quickly right they start off as almost
competitors she's a thief he's trying to
save the the artifacts for the college
and she's trying to sell it uh for money
I mean there's really no reason besides
that she just wants to get rich off it
or that she wants to find what happened
to her dad and I guess it kind of
becomes a uh companionship when they
realize that she needs to find this
artifact that will you know kind of
figure out what something happened with
her dad and then he wants to help out
with her with her it does feel like
there's a little like a missing piece
between these two moments and like where
they decided to become allies in this
relationship so yeah like she it would
have been fun to see the whole movie
She's a thief yeah and then something
organically happens where she gets
pulled by Indy or the opposite like it
was always about her dad it was always
about you know fulfilling his legacy and
and reconciling that relationship but I
feel like it was one and then it was the
other and then it was both and I was a
little it was more the character Arc had
nothing to do with her performance yeah
I thought as an actress overall she was
great I agree
um some another thing that people talked
about was the fact that Indy did and we
touched on this a little bit Indy was a
little bit more downtrodden in the
beginning but I was thinking to myself
like can you imagine if Mangold had
written it
um where Indy was like this Hero at
school and everything was great like
where do you go from there if he's still
he almost and and I do feel like Indiana
or like Harrison wouldn't have wanted to
come back if it didn't have he talks
over and over interviews about character
and story and there has to be a reason
for this story to exist yeah so where
would they have gone if he was still
great if everything was still great in
his life I don't know and I'm glad they
don't make him or they start off the
movie as like uh this he's this big hero
that everybody loves I mean I don't know
what what the movie's purpose is at that
point I mean he's Indiana Jones we
already love him like there's no reason
to make another movie where he's just
the big action hero star again I mean I
like that we start off with
Indiana Jones is retiring he's moving on
he's ready to just live his life out as
a divorcee an unhappy divorce a but a
divorcee uh I like that I think that
makes sense to have him pulled into this
new new adventure is because of someone
like Helena I don't think it would make
sense to kind of have him start all over
again because the big question is why
why would he want to get involved in
another venture at his point in that
life and there's nothing wrong with
being 80 but if he was like
like hey I'm ready for another one and
didn't reluctantly get pulled in you'd
be like dude like chill out like yeah
it's time to retire but because we got
the opposite people are like well did he
have to be that way but I I mean there's
even a scene that he has with um his
friend I'm gonna already always miss his
name
um but the friend from Last Crusade or I
believe and Salah yeah so he has that
moment where he's like oh I want to go
with you I want to go on this adventure
and he's like no you don't like I have
to go because of XY reason like you
don't like we had that time in our life
but now it's time for us to just move on
and I think that's like kind of that
maybe that response to the audience
where it's like well why isn't Indy the
the big action stars like well because
he doesn't need to be anymore so yeah
maybe that's what we're supposed to take
from it yeah uh the one issue I did have
with Indy was throwing the clock was it
the gift that he got from this oh yeah
he gave it to the homeless guy I was
like dude well he probably has a lot of
clogs at home I don't know dude that was
mean
I'll get you a clock for Christmas I
just I didn't understand as a character
Choice like why he was doing that it was
almost like he didn't Revere anything
anymore like instead of
I don't know I think they're really
trying to hit home that he's like this
not I want to say miserable but
definitely an unhappy person in his life
he gets home he looks at the divorce
papers puts the magnet on Marion's face
like he's clearly not at a place in his
life
yeah yeah I put some egg down on her
face and then at the very end he moves
the magnet because she's there he's like
I don't want her to see that the thing I
did appreciate was him being pissed at
the college students for making so much
noise because I apprec I can't stand
when people are noisy around me my
neighbors so I was like you go Indy
although it was Moon Moon day I mean I
gotta be a little bit excited that it's
Moon day people are landing on the moon
I don't know if I'd be pretty excited
but well speaking of moon day let's talk
about sort of the big action set pieces
there was the opening sequence on the
train the parade obviously you have the
talk talk stuff in Morocco
um and then the time travel stuff do you
have a favorite
set piece and what did you feel about
the de-aging in the um wow so lots of
tackle here I I do big questions a lot
of tackle I I you know what I wasn't
even mention I do like the scene where
they go underwater as well to the ship
yes I forgot about that Antonio but yes
Antonio Bandera is great in this role
not enough of him in my opinion but
right in the role I do like that scene I
think it's fun to kind of go in there
and use eels as the place for snakes I
thought that was kind of a clever way
yes to incorporate that I do like the
final scene so the time travel scene I'm
all on board I'll be completely honest
on board you said that I loved it well I
know we're gonna get to like is it too
ridiculous later but I will just say now
I'm a big fan of it and I have my
defense later but so I like that a lot I
think the beginning action set piece on
the train
like the tuck tuck scene is a little bit
too long and especially why the train
team doesn't work for me is because we
spend way too much time with a de-aged
you know Harrison Ford which I think
overall doesn't look bad I think it
looks good but we spent so much time
with it it does become a little bit
uncanny after some points and it just
lasts a little bit too long there's
sometimes I I just was like watching it
and it again felt like a fast and
furious movie I mean there's a moment
where mads Mickelson's character gets
slammed in the face by this like pole
and my whole audience just reacted this
were like oh my gosh that's it so hard
he's done he's dead but he's not dead he
comes back later and I think some people
are just like it's a little a little a
lot a lot going on and I'm not sure it
gets a little dark at the end and it
kind of feels like they're it's dark
intentionally because it's trying to
hide us you know from the CGI D aging
face so I'm not a big fan of the action
or the train scene but I do like the the
underwater scene a lot I think it's a
lot of fun and the time travel big fan
of that I love that the planes are just
there flying above these you know these
Roman armies or Sicilian armies whatever
armies they are I think that was a lot
of fun I'm a big fan of that and yeah
the way I think the way it was executed
was great yeah oh there's a there's a
moment where uh the plane is flying into
like the eye of the storm and it kind of
does this wide shot that's exactly what
I was thinking so cool to see it it's
like oh are they gonna do it I remember
watching this movie thinking are they
gonna do it are they gonna time travel
right now and they do it and I I was
bundle of joy when that happens well and
and I don't think has time travel been a
done in that way before where it's
actually a plane flying into this you
know like it was original it was it
wasn't this magical
kind of like snap your fingers thing
yeah well we're in a world now where
time travels like in every movie every
month at some point right yeah I think
in June alone there was two movies about
time travel three to be honest I mean we
got the flashes time travel uh
Spider-Man's trying time travel
Multiverse now we're doing Indiana Jones
time travel so time travel is a hot hot
thing right now and so you can do it in
a million different ways and I think
this one was a lot of fun to think back
to the future is one of my favorite
movies of all time so time travel is a
thing that I do love so I was your
target audience for this whole thing
um when you said the flash it reminded
me of like fan service yeah well The
Flash is done in a different way way too
much fan services yeah
um when you were talking about
um Keith week one uh but yeah so I I
actually so many people said
that I heard said they had a problem
with Harrison's voice during the Aging
perks he sounded older I didn't notice
it I was so mesmerized I didn't give two
crafts this is amazing because I do love
me Sam Harrison Ford from back in the
day and it was giving me the Vibes and I
I absolutely loved it and I thought it
was a great way to
um it was so smart like it was just so
smart to put this element into the movie
and some people felt like you didn't
need it I'm like are you freaking
kidding me you're connecting three
movies that came out in the 80s of
course one came out in early 2000s but
we haven't seen this character in so
long like this is a great way to connect
the dots and is
I mean everybody was like oh well I
could tell when he started moving I was
Hook Line Sinker you got me yeah we've
seen worse I think it looks good overall
I think sometimes I think that scene
looks great when he's in the train he's
kind of going through the the
compartments and he's taking the the uh
at that point it's not at the dial it's
like a sword of some sort and uh I love
all those moments where he's like hiding
with the other Nazis and then he punches
mads Mickelson all those moments are
great I think when they he gets on top
of the train he's like running along and
he gets that big fight I think then we
get into like a little sketchy territory
that was a little more CG too yeah like
more CG heavy but overall I think it's
like it's a a necessary scene to really
connect those dots like you said I mean
we're a lot of the Indiana Jones I mean
Last Crusade starts with the flashback
as well but that's a much different
flashback but that's like my favorite
part of the Last Crusade is that
flashback so I think the flashback is
necessary to really set the stage of
totally the dial of these characters
even if mads Mickelson gets hit in the
head real hard I think it's important
that we know who he is that and that way
they get into Marvel territory where
somebody gets hit so hard they should be
dead but yeah I mean my audience we're
all agree with you my audience was very
like whoa is that it is come back to
life exactly well they could have done
something with like maybe Resurrection
the dial who knows but you know who
knows see we're all writers in our heads
we are we are to an extent rewriting but
now overall I like that secret I mean I
really did like all of the action set
pieces I think the Morocco stuff was my
favorite just because the talk talk it
felt very classically Indie to me and I
liked the aesthetic and the movement of
it and the you know it just had a pace
the whole thing felt like I was like
holding my breath
um and it didn't feel like it went on
too long it felt it felt super cohesive
and super Indie and those were the
moments that I liked personally the best
um but yeah I did I did enjoy the time
travel would be a close second
um
so okay so this is the moment I'm gonna
ask you to rank
the original trilogy okay the original
trilogy yeah there is a right answer
according to you yeah so I'm a little
nervous to do this right now but here's
what I'll throw out okay and then you
know audience can judge me as you will
but I'm gonna go uh Last Crusade Raiders
and then Temple that's how I would go
yeah now now I think it's important to
note with a little asterisk I love them
all dearly I love them you know two
different capacities but I love them all
I I do I'm a big fan of Last Crusade I
think Last Crusade is maybe my favorite
so that's how I would do it okay so what
is yours what is the right one
the correct answer is Temple of Doom wow
Raiders and then Last Crusade literally
the op timize okay
part that I'm gonna throw into this
equation my favorite franchise of all
time is Bond and my favorite
Bond of all time is Connery okay so why
is it my number three I don't know
there's I don't know for me I I it just
I they were all great that's the thing
like how do you choose children between
your children exactly but I think that
one for me
I wasn't a hundred percent and maybe
it's because Connery was only 12 years
older than Harrison Ford at the time but
it didn't 100 feel like father son all
the time interesting
maybe felt like Uncle but um
I think just I just love Temple of Doom
I love the darkness of it I love the
opening sequence is my favorite opening
the musical is great yeah I loved I
loved all the characters in it
um
yeah I just I just I loved the fact that
you had this Starlet kind of along for
the ride that was sort of a fish out of
water yeah
um yeah and the obvious I think tubble
Doom is good I think I like it I don't
know if it's aged the best out of all
the other Indiana Jones movies and
that's maybe why it tends to be on a lot
of people's lower half of the rankings I
will say I love your ranking I will say
I think mine's a little more popular
than yours so yours is definitely but
sometimes it's Raiders first many times
it's Raiders first and I don't blame
anybody who having Raiders first I mean
it's always hard so Raiders of the Lost
Ark like it's always hard to beat the
original of anything because of it's the
original and everything is building off
of that so that's always hard but yeah I
would I would it's the opposite now can
you put this film into
that's tough to say you know before this
episode recorded we were talking about
you know can you compare a dial of
Destiny to the original Three you know
maybe you can compare it to cringing
into the Crystal Skull but how do you
compare a movie from 2023 from a movie
in the 80s that's uh it's really tough
to do we're talking not just
character-wise but we're talking
technology and action everything is just
much different now
um so it's hard to compare this to the
original and I think maybe a part of uh
what people problems or issues maybe
people might have a dial Destiny is that
it does sometimes feel like they're
attempting to capture this like
spielbergian charm that the original
Three had when is that even possible is
it even possible to make a movie that
has that charm from the original Three
arguably it's not and so sometimes it
feels like it's trying to be like that
the classic Indiana Jones but it's just
we're living in a different time now I
don't know if we can ever recapture that
magic so it's hard to say what do you
what do you think can you I don't think
I can at this point yeah and we did talk
about this so it's an unfair question
that I asked you because I think yeah
okay so the last film maybe the fourth
you could compare a little bit
um which I didn't mind that film because
I think I was just getting into this
business when that film came out so I
think it was one of the first screenings
I ever went to and you know where Shia
was like a hot actor at the time right
like and I thought he was like a perfect
choice as his son at the time
um maybe that one for me hasn't aged as
well well but I at the time I was
delighted and it was also so much
anticipation around like the first film
from the original trilogy so just great
to have him back and then this one he is
at such a different place in his life so
I just think it's so hard you're talking
about films that we sat with for 40
years or 30 or Wherever Whenever However
ever old you were when you saw the first
ones versus a film that we just saw a
few weeks ago yeah and
this is clearly something like when I
look at mangold's filmography one thing
that I did say to Harrison when I talked
to him I was like the thing I love about
James mangle as a director if you watch
a Tarantino movie you know it's a
Tarantino movie if you watch a Wes
Anderson movie you know it's a Wes
Anderson movie without even knowing the
director James Mangold is so varied as a
director he's given us so many different
genres and styles but it wasn't until I
started thinking about this movie I
started thinking the one thing that he
does I could say is a bit of a through
line in some of his films is that sort
of man that's later in life downtrodden
down on his luck Walk the Line Logan
Ford V Ferrari but although that was to
a certain certain degree
um it wasn't the classic young upstart
hero yeah
um was a guy that's sort of been passed
over and so that's sort of the common
thread and I and I know Harrison and
James are very good friends and I was
sort of I'm picturing the conversations
they were having about this film as
James was rewriting the original script
and as they were discussing and I think
the one thing that kept coming back to
them is Harrison was like we need to
have a reason to have this movie it
can't just be a movie for movie's sake
and so I could just picture Harrison
reading that script
oh yeah this is some great character
stuff here like I'm down on my luck I'm
this I'm that so in that sense
I I really appreciate that there was
another level to Indy that we didn't see
before so to Circle back to the original
question which is why I can't compare
it's a different person 40 years later
and people who are going to say well top
gun Maverick
came back and did a movie 35 years later
that one said in present day that one
brought in a whole new generation of
actors to appeal to a younger generation
this one to me felt very classically
Indie and when you say spielbergian I
agree but if it didn't
where would we be as a as a film if we
didn't have that element you know yeah
no I completely agree I mean I I think
it's interesting that Crystal Skull I
think is going through a little bit of a
Reclamation right now I think a lot of
people are going back to it and saying
it maybe isn't as bad as we thought
initially and maybe that's because it's
been over 10 years since we got it and
maybe in 10 years and we'll look at dial
Destiny and say yeah that was something
that was necessary for the conclusion of
Indiana Jones uh it is maybe a little
too early to say like whether where it
sits in the franchise because it is so
drastically different from The Originals
it's almost unfair to compare them yeah
and I think the thing to glean from this
too is
I guess it sort of shows you what side
I'm on when I started seeing the
audience score come in over the weekend
and it was like 88 and I was like my
heart is full I'm so happy that people
are enjoying this movie yeah I think
it's hard not even someone like me who
may not have like loved this movie
because I also had really high
expectations I love Mangold and I love
Indiana Jones but even somebody who
didn't like maybe love love love this
movie I still really enjoyed it I still
had a great time watching it it was fun
to watch all the kind of Adventure romps
again and go through these uh these
moments we'd even talk about all the
puzzle solving scenes which I think are
my favorite moments you know when
Helena's on the boat and she's like
reading off the uh the translation and
like kind of going through them like
students love that scene big fan of that
moment or when they're in
Italy I think they're going through the
cave and they're doing like classic
puzzle solving scenes it really felt
like nostalgic Indie and that's some of
the best moments of the movie for me
yeah and I think those are things that
are going to age well too like yeah
you're saying and you actually answered
my question because that was my next
question was like your favorite elements
of some of your favorite elements of the
film and yeah when you think about like
when I think about mission impossible as
a franchise the thing that I love about
that is the twists I always have these
cool twists this one it is the puzzle
solving element of it and nobody
delivers a one-liner like Indiana Jones
no like he's just all of that doesn't
matter how old you are that irreverent
don't take yourself too seriously charm
every grin is earned you know it's just
it was still all there yeah it was and
like you said we talked about the
plateaus a few times about the time
travel thing and on we're going to talk
about Howard if it was too ridiculous
well audiences think it's too ridiculous
I I will argue back and forth that it's
not too ridiculous and yeah Jones has
always been a franchise of some
ridiculous things but first movie
people's faces melt off the second movie
there's Voodoo and Witchcraft and the
third movie was a Holy Grail the fourth
movie they met aliens I mean literal
aliens and UFOs I don't think it's too
ridiculous for a movie like Indiana
Jones to go in time travel I love that
they committed to that I think that's
what I think something that will age
really well in the future it's like they
committed they went for it I almost wish
they spent more time in uh ancient
Sicily if I'll be honest I think that
could have been a longer sequence yeah
but they could have been they could have
interacted because they were always at a
distance correct yeah interacting with
the the people there interacting with
Archimedes a lot more I think there
there's more there that could have been
explored and I would have been happy to
spend the last maybe 30 45 minutes there
instead but instead of the train yeah
figure out how to get out and that type
of thing yeah it could have been pretty
fun so oh that would have been really
fun we're all writers in our hand like
you said yeah that you're right that
could have been a longer it could have
been longer it feels like it was a
button yeah when it could have been a
little bit
um but no I don't think it was
ridiculous at all because it's in the
trailer and I don't even know if it was
in the Final Cut but it was in the
trailer where Harrison says
I don't know if I don't believe in magic
but I've seen some things yes yeah yeah
and he definitely saw the thing and that
that is actually I think my favorite
moment in the film is seeing his Joy
watching history unfold unfold in front
of him yeah I agree that moment still
like I think the only part I don't like
about that moment in the time travel
sequence is this slightly underwhelming
death scene of uh meds Mickelson's
character I thought I wanted something a
little bit more exciting a little bit
more rewarding but I mean he gets his
comeuppance by crashing in a plane but
other than that I mean I love that
before that moment you see that
sarcophagus with like the dragon on it
they're like this dragon has propellers
on it and it's like leading up to this
moment that you don't think could happen
and then even leading up to the time
travel part where they're on the plane
and Harrison's like continental drift
continental drift you're gonna get it
wrong and there's that moment are they
gonna get it wrong just some really
great tension building and when they do
quietly commit to it I I love it big fan
yeah Harrison overall
doing some great doing his best work
he's shrinking he'll probably be
nominated for an Emmy this is true but
he's very possibly going to get
nominated for her for an Emmy
um so did you think this was better than
Crystal Skull in your opinion if we're
gonna go there if we're gonna go there I
I did re-watch Crystal recently kind of
to prepare for re-watching this movie
and I think there's some things it's
doing that's a lot of fun like you said
at the time Shia for Mutt Williams was
like the perfect choice and I think they
play into that role really well there
are some things that are interesting
choices story-wise I mean the meeting of
the aliens is is definitely out there
and it's definitely interesting but you
know looking back at it now it's it's
kind of fun
um the CGI back then I think was panned
a lot I'm looking at it now I'm like
it's not that bad it you know it is what
it was at that time
I don't know I'm kind of at a toss-up
right now I think I liked about Disney
slightly more than Crystal Skull but I
don't also don't think Crystal Skull is
uh is bad by any stretch of the
imagination so yeah I and I like I said
I liked it too but I would still say
this one's better yeah because I think
it feels more in alignment with the
original yeah tonally with the original
okay and and sticking to that like I
said classic
let's not let's Revere Our Heroes of
film instead of bashing them and telling
them what they should have done better
in 2023 yeah
um so let's talk about speaking of which
the box office okay
um
60 million not amazing
um thoughts on why it was 60 and
yeah that's a tough question to unpack
because you know what goes into
this box office like who's seeing this
movie I guess it's like kind of the
foundation question who is going to see
Indiana Jones the dial Destiny so you
have your your Die Hard fans Deanna
Jones you and I people who grew up at
the movies uh families who grew up with
it they're going to go see this movie
regardless of what who says what they're
gonna go see it
um but we're now in a point we're in
2023 uh gen Z's grown up they're they're
buying tickets and if they're not
growing up with Indiana Jones what
motivation do they have to go see
Indiana Jones at this point what is the
draw if they never grew up watching
Raiders or Last Crusade or Temple
what is pushing them to go see this
movie I mean if people aren't going to
go see Marvel movies as much
what's going to be different about dial
Destiny is kind of the question at hand
and I don't know how to answer that like
at this point
you just have to make a movie that's
going to blow somebody away but I'm not
sure if there's anything like the action
sequences may be fun but there's nothing
in there that they haven't seen in a
fast and furious movie they haven't seen
in the MCU movie
um Harrison Ford plus his soul but he's
not gonna be doing his own stunts uh
like Tom Cruise so if that's not the
appeal then what's going to be the
appeal and I think that's the question
that is hard to answer how do you what
do you think
I think it's a lot of things I think
it's a very crowded movie season I think
that is the biggest reason personally I
think aside from because like some
people were saying oh it's because the
review at a can I'm like most people in
America don't care don't even pay
attention to can or even notice or even
think about or even see a score or read
reviews they may be in the news hear
something about oh they had a Premiere
and that's the the gist of it I think we
are in a summer's movie Seasons which is
great for us as audience members where
every single weekend you have a
blockbuster film opening you have in the
case of barberheimer two movies opening
in the same weekend and that just sort
of shows you the landscape that neither
one of them that they're going to keep
it that way and some of it's due to the
build up from the pandemic and things
getting delayed but we are spoiled for
choice and we still have stuff at home
we can watch and so I think it's really
hard
for any movie to break through and
become
I don't think you can have
record-breaking numbers every single
weekend and I think that is a huge part
of it I think people and I just know
because I'm from a small town and I know
how my family and friends decide to go
to the movies and they'll you know
they'll see a couple movies this summer
and
they maybe it just wasn't like on their
radar it's like oh this is priority for
me so I think it's one of those that's
gonna play well I hate to say this later
on but when it comes out on streaming I
think it's one of those that everybody's
going to want to watch if they didn't
catch it in theaters but I do I agree
with you I think the demo like was 40
um 42 people over 45 and mostly male or
a higher percentage of male female split
than normal and so it was a Nostalgia
play for a lot of people like you and I
are movie aficionados we'd love to
franchise but you're right like I would
ask and I always reference my nephew on
the show but when I have sometimes I I
I judge the Zeitgeist by what he says
yeah if I'm like are you excited to see
Indiana Jones and he he hasn't seen the
original trilogy even though he's a
movie fan
um so yeah I think maybe it was sort of
dialing into that sort of younger demo
that they're super super motivated to go
and see it several times yeah my only
Counterpoint to what you said is that
while there is a plethora of options to
go see
in June I mean three movies alone have
been flopping so if people aren't going
to go see the movies before Ian Jones at
that point it's like not a question of
like choices it's just why aren't people
seeing Jones clearly no one's seeing
Elemental and no one's seeing the flash
um nothing's no no one's watching
anything in June except for Spider-Man
which came out the first week of June so
it's interesting because there are
choices but people aren't choosing those
movies either yeah and but that's sort
of I think we're saying the same thing
because
you know there's certain people I know
will be like Oh I'm definitely gonna go
see Mission I'm definitely going to go
see Barbie and it's not that they didn't
want to see Indiana Jones it's that they
have their priorities maybe and maybe
that wasn't a priority yeah
um because it didn't have like it had
more of a Nostalgia feel so it's like
are you racing to the theater to see
something nostalgic are you racing to
see something that you've never seen
before or you know it's just like people
do pick and choose so I do think it's
hard to have
you know in a summer in a summer of 2023
or whatever summer it is aside from the
pandemic like seven or eight
record-breaking movies and you make
another good point in terms of the
streaming and I think a lot of people
have brought this up to me as a
potential reason why people aren't going
to the movies one the movies are still
expensive it's an expensive outing for a
family of four to go see a movie
two what is the motivation to go see a
movie especially a Disney movie when you
know it may be on Disney Plus in three
to four months if that's the case for
every everything to some extent
everything but you know for sure Disney
they have a dedicated a dedicated
streaming service streaming platform you
know that uh quantumania will be on
streaming in three to four months you
know it's gonna be that place Netflix
and Max and all these other places you
may not know if they're gonna go there
maybe at some point in a year maybe six
to eight months but you don't know for
sure because it's not made by you know
Max or Netflix
um so it's hard to say but like I know
some people will say to me if the
initial reaction to Quantum Mania aren't
very good why would I go watch it when I
can just watch it in Disney Plus in four
months so it's like well that is a good
point like I can't I can't argue against
that so I'm wondering if this movie does
Go Disney Plus at some point because it
will
um what will be the amount of people
streaming it versus the first time they
watch it versus the second time they
watch it it'll be really interesting to
see and it's nice to know that the
people who have seen it are really
liking it score is so high and I think
it is going to be one of those where
people are going to be like oh my gosh
it was so good I wish I saw it in
theaters it would have been so fun it
will be one of those things I think it
will because I think it did it is one of
those films that you know I was
completely like transformed into like a
little girl watching it watching some of
those classic things and like the
excitement level around watching that
character but again it's like you're
you know sometimes when people
prioritize certain movies it's because
the newsiness of it right like a Marvel
film okay well I gotta find out what's
gonna happen in Infinity war end game or
this like I gotta go see it opening
weekend or you know or there's a buzz
there's a certain there's like a buzz
you feel in the air about certain films
that they just have this momentum and
this one unfortunately
I was hoping oh I was hoping I was
hoping so much but I am thrilled that
people who are seeing it are loving it
to sort of set that initial
um where do you think the franchise goes
from here
that's a good question I don't think it
goes away that's my short answer it's
not going away maybe take a break for
five years or so you know take that
moment to kind of recalibrate and figure
out where they want to go
you know does Phoebe wallerbridge Don
the Hat the Fedora and the Whip and
become the new you know Indiana Jones
possibly I I would be more than okay
with that
um you and I were talking before that
there is this you know big fan casting
wish to Kiki Quan kind of to shift the
focus from Indiana Jones let's not go to
Kiki Quan and focus on his character
which is I think not a terrible idea I
mean he's a beloved actor he's a beloved
character in the franchise it's a good
way to keep it within the Indiana
franchise but focus on something
different
um I don't know where it goes I do think
we need a little break maybe five more
years and we'll resume do we do a TV
show do we try to do a Disney plus thing
I don't know do we cast a different
person I have no idea what do you want
to do what do you want to see I have one
person people can hate me for this
Chris Pratt Chris Pratt as that was a
rumor for a long time that people
thought and I as I initially I was like
no he's done so many franchises but
freaking Guardians three I'm sorry he
was so damn good and he reminded me of
why he is a movie star he has the same
Essence I think of an Indiana Jones like
when I picture people putting on the hat
I'm not even saying he has to put on the
hat but in continuing the adventure in
some way that's where I don't know how
they would do it because he was never
established and I don't think it's a
reboot of a franchise with a younger
because then I think he would even go
younger and cast somebody in their 20s
but he seems to be the obvious choice in
terms of somebody who I could picture
pulling off the humor the action
being overall just likable he to me
works for some reason I feel like a TV
series Works although I don't know if he
needs to do it like not needs to but I
don't know if you would get Pratt to do
a TV series or maybe if you do a series
you do reboot it choose somebody younger
or would have been cool if Short Round
was established in this movie in some
sense so he's not Indiana but you pick
up the adventure from his perspective
and you go on a whole new adventure with
this character that you know and love
and we know he can pull off like he
makes you feel he makes you laugh he
makes you cry he's wonderfully lovable
and you you do take it in a different
direction so there's lots of places to
go I don't think it has to go away but I
actually and you're gonna think I'm a
bit crazier but when the movie ended I
was like I think Harrison's got one more
in them oh wow one more I think he's got
out one more maybe maybe Marion can do a
one more I guess I don't know if we will
get it I don't know I don't think we're
gonna get it yeah Chris Pratt might be
booked and busy I mean we hit now Mario
and uh I think he's gonna be in Garfield
now so I mean if that takes off there's
another franchise that will likely want
to use him more uh you know so we'll see
with that I don't know I don't think the
franchise ends I don't think they're
gonna get rid of this property I don't
think they need to they don't need to
tell you we uh we it's been so long and
so why not continue it in a new and
fresh and different way but again like
it would have to be justified but at the
same time like
Chris Pratt does love Disney he has a
great relationship with Disney and
Marvel and Chris Pratt loves to work and
I appreciate that about him he's not
like oh no I don't want to do this or I
don't want to do that he's not not
impossible people doubted him like about
a year ago there was all this sort of
backlash against Chris Pratt and I'm
like he nailed Mario Guardians like his
box office totals for that somebody's
got a total Rotten Tomatoes total his
box office for the past year because
he's crushing it oh I mean over 2
billion probably yeah so I mean Mario
itself made a billion so that's not a
bad choice and sense of trying to
re-establish a franchise and try to
bring audiences in at all but the
question I think really at the hand is
are they what are they going to do it at
what point and then like you said so
many Logistics to it where do we start
do we do a reboot is it a different
story is it it's like Where Do We Begin
Again yeah is the real question I think
that this is a question they're going to
be asking for a lot of their franchises
Star Wars ended now they're like okay
are we doing a sequel looks like they
are gonna do a sequel but this is kind
of the question they're asking all these
franchises are quote unquote ending but
then they want to continue on so it's
it's hard to say that just opened a
whole can of worms and that's probably a
good place to end this then that works
for me another episode that works for me
um Joe this was a delight it was great
chatting with you you had so many
refreshing ideas and thoughts and
changed my mind about a few things oh
great so thank you for joining and let
everybody know where they can find you
yes thank you so much for having me on I
really appreciate it hopefully if I
change your mind on anything it's to
revisit Last Crusade one more time and
give it a second chance uh because I
think it's very good but uh you can find
me on Tick Tock Instagram at Cinema Joe
that's where I post most my reviews and
discussions and rankings uh my own
podcast house Cinema podcast we talk
about movies and uh yeah that's about it
and you're you're a delight you're a
delight to chat thank you so much thank
you again I'm Kieran for joining oh yes
Karen Karen if you're listening to this
you want to do a podcast together
season of succession because then maybe
we could you know maybe if maybe if it's
like a Roman s like centered story that
works for me sure
there we go Roman had her brother
thank you all for all for watching my
great wishes
on Destiny in the theaters
I agree but I guess if you're here you
are
you right well maybe just go see it
again
but thank you so much for joining us on
this episode of the after show and we
will see you on the next one bye